FOR MOM AND DAD TO WATCH THEIR
HAVING AN UNBELIEVABLE YEAEA RA
THE  ONE, A BRUTAL READ
BY THE LEAFS HERE IN THE MIDDLE
.
WINDS IT AHEAD FOR CLIFFORD.THE
EARLIER.
LOOK AT THIS, SOLID PLAY BEHIND
LITTLE BIT.LINEUP, IT'S HIM.
LAST YEAR,  NOW THE
REBOUND KNOCKED E MOVE, THE
KIN.
HE E H MARNER A DANGEROUS SHIFT.
HIS FIRST SHOT SHORTPUCK.
BUT THERE IS NO LY AND OETTINGE
MAKES THE STOP.
>> Ray: CLOSE CALLS BOTH ENDS OF
THE ICE AS JUSTIN HOLL
SEGUIN BACK TO
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF ROOM.
THE PUCK IS THERE AND YOU'RE
IN THE GAME AS GURIANOV WOR
TAVARES WALKS IN AND SHOOTSTS G
AWAY FROM FA
THE FIRST TIME YOU SEE HIM, HEE.
IN, SHOOTS, DROHERE, THE
LEAFS BENCH IS SC
AWAY COMES NYLANDER FOR
>> Gord: KERFOOT...
DROPS IT BACK OFF TBELIEVABLE S.
NYLANDER DEFLECTS IT ONE-HANDED
.
RASMUS SANDIN WORKS IT BACK
SHO.
DROPPED BACK TO S S HARD SHOT A
ENGVALL...ITH
BACK AND PAVELSKI.
RIELLY ON  FOR
HIM.
YOU LOVE THE WAY HE DRIVES THE
NET.
HE PLAYS WITH SUC